we've now reached the stage in Democrats
midterm election desperation where
they've given up on touting their
achievements of which there are none and
they've even given up smearing the
Republicans which they've tried since
the beginning of October to basically no
effect and we're now in the phase where
they're just straight up lying about
basic facts about the very recent past
the most common price of gas in America
is 3.39 down from over five dollars when
I took office
none of that is true
first of all I'm not even sure what
Biden means by the most common price of
gas does he mean the mode as in mean
median and mode like you learned in
middle school if he does that is a
completely meaningless number even if it
were correct which I doubt that it is
the average price of gas which he may
have been trying to say and which is the
actual measure that we use to track gas
prices that is a lot higher than he said
yesterday
I mean not a lot not like ten dollars
higher but it's high it's significantly
higher it's three dollars and seventy
six cents and then the price of gas when
Biden took office was not over five
dollars it was actually two dollars and
39 cents meaning gas prices have not
dropped at least 32 since Biden's been
in office they've actually jumped more
than 57 percent
not even close on any of those numbers
but Joe knows that
if his price numbers were correct his
poll numbers would be much higher but
the Democrats poll numbers are low and
dropping faster and faster by the minute
as we're now 11 days out from election
day I'm Michael Knowles this the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from Mac who says
it is true that it's dangerous to let
your children go back to public school
just not for the reasons they say well
that's true I've said since the
beginning wow there would be a lot of
negative consequences to the kids being
shut out of public school it was
actually probably one of the Silver
Linings of the storm cloud of covid
uh yes your kid isn't learning
arithmetic your kid probably wasn't
learning arithmetic in school anyway but
at least now your kid isn't being taught
that he's actually a little girl yeah at
least now he's not being taught
genderqueer by Maya kababi so there's
always a silver lining okay the glass
can in fact be half full when we want to
get the truth out there we've got to
speak to one another when you want to
talk to your friends and family you got
to check out pure talk right now head on
over to puretalk.com enter code Knowles
with midterms coming up here is
something you should keep in mind every
dollar you spend is a boat and you're
casting those votes over and over again
for companies that are working hard to
undermine your values for instance
Verizon Wireless customers you're
supporting a company that canceled one
America news for its support of
President Trump a t your wireless
customer your wireless customer at T
customers your wireless provider does
not just support far left CNN it owns it
T-Mobile customers your CEO openly
advised them Democrats on how to beat
Trump in the 2020 election do not give
your money to woke wireless companies
give it to pure talk instead pure talk
not only believes in conservative
American Family Values but it also gives
you the best service at a low cost
unlimited talk text and plenty of data
for just thirty dollars a month the
average family saves almost one thousand
dollars per year that is a thousand
fewer votes for those cell phone
companies that want to stop you from
speaking freely I am a Pure Talk
customer I absolutely love it here's
what I like same network same coverage
same phone lower Bill and 30 days risk
free right now is your chance to show
Corporate America that you are done
funding their left-wing ideology go to
puretalk.com and enter code Knowles to
save 50 off your first month that's
purechalk.com promo code Knowles for 50
off your first month it's about to
become a lot more difficult for the
Democrats to lie
and this of course would be because
the way that the Democrats project their
lies and censor the truth from getting
out is through social media which is the
new Public Square and is has been
controlled entirely by the libs
until now
Mr musk Mr Elon Musk walks into Twitter
headquarters carrying the sink and we're
all waiting what's going to happen is he
going to do anything is there going to
be a big change well now
we've seen the first big change Elon
Musk decapitating the leadership of
Twitter hours after becoming the owner
of Twitter Elon Musk just destroyed four
of the company's Executives with facts
logic and pink slips this would include
the CEO of Twitter
and more importantly this would include
Vijaya Gaddy I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that correctly but Vijaya
Gaddy was twitters at the time top legal
and policy executive when she led the
team that banned Donald Trump
which is I
I don't think it can be overstated how
significant this event was this was a
moment when woke oligarchs in Silicon
Valley that have basically no
accountability to the American
electorate came in and decided to kick
the duly elected sitting president of
the United States out of the Public
Square
this is one of the most Brazen power
grabs in the history of the United
States you might even call it a
fundamental reordering of the American
political order
and it was because this chick Vijaya
Gaddy at Twitter decided to do it and
after that you saw Facebook follow suit
and Google follow suit so she's gone
she's gone really really uh good news
the execs are going to get some payouts
and this includes prag agrawal the CEO
the CFO Ned Siegel general counsel Sean
Ed get they're going to make 88 million
bucks out of it again a small price to
pay especially if you're Elon Musk to
get rid of these people really really
good stuff I've said the whole time I
don't know how the Elon Musk tenure at
Twitter is going to go I'm pretty
hopeful the guy is clearly not a leftist
he's not a hardcore leftist at least is
he a conservative that I'm not I just
don't know I don't know the man and he's
an eccentric public figure but
I said I'll wait and see
all right from what we are seeing things
are moving very much in the right
direction the one thing that Elon could
do that I sort of hope he doesn't do
I hope he doesn't ban pseudonymous
accounts he has said before that he
might ban pseudonymous accounts the idea
that people really
ought to uh stand behind their words and
I think there's a lot to that but one of
the issues if you want to restore
anything resembling the tradition of
free speech in America
you need to recognize that it's not just
about overt censorship but it's about
this this well the cancel culture it's
about this perverse sort of system of
standards that we have today where you
it's not just that you lose your social
media account if you say true things
that are Politically Incorrect but you
could face professional consequences you
could face consequences in your school
you could be ostracized you could be
investigated by the federal government
for that matter and so it with a a
current Free Speech regime throughout
the country that is so perverse that is
so hostile to the true things and to
good things into the moral order
pseudonymous accounts are actually one
way to free up speech a little bit
the fact that the fact that
probably my favorite accounts on Twitter
are not accountants with people's real
pictures and real names attached to them
but part of that is because
those accounts don't need to worry about
being fired about being investigated
about being kicked out of school so they
can say things that are true and funny
and good and so I hope Elon as he purges
the Bots as he lifts the insane woke
rules on speech as he fires the people
who were enforcing this this leftist
censorship policy I hope he doesn't
doesn't go a little bit too far or you
know Blast away with a shotgun that that
takes out some good things too the
pseudonymous counts I think need to to
stay I'm very Pro sued anyway
all of this is very good news for
conservatives and then we're matching
that with really really good news on the
political front heading into the midterm
elections the polls right now are
looking good the generic ballot that was
just released by USA Today not a
right-wing Outlet a a center to Center
left Outlet it shows Republicans up four
points over Democrats that's 49 to 45.
a huge Change USA Today
uh previously in July said Democrats
were leading the Republicans 44
to 40. so that's just a complete flip
previously the Democrats were up by four
now the Republicans are up by four so
that's a Delta of eight uh and it's even
better than that there's one analyst
uh the Mason-Dixon polling management
direct managing director uh Brad Coker
just told daily wire that he thinks
actually the polling averages are
underestimating Republican support by
about five percentage points
so he says I think the GOP will end up
with 54 Senate seats I don't track house
races District by District but I
generally think the Republican party
will net a gain of somewhere between 25
and 35 seats I saw my friend Ted Cruz
the other night we had dinner that
extended late into the night and one of
the big questions we were all debating
at this dinner
what's the number of Republican Senate
seats that we're going to get and I tell
you I've
been having these debates and
conversations with Senator Cruz actually
and and with other people as well for
six months now
and six months ago people were saying I
don't know maybe we'll get 51 seats
maybe 52 seats for a while people were
saying we're not we're actually not
going to retake the Senate uh 55 45 we
retake the Senate maybe now I'm feeling
a little more confident a little
at this dinner very smart people who
were very involved in this and keeping
their eyes on the uh on the data all the
time they're saying I don't know 52
seats 53 seats
some people even saying 54 which seems
ambitious but could be happening look at
the individual races Blake Masters right
now who people wrote off they wrote him
off months ago even a lot of
conservatives and I love Blake Masters I
think the guy's a great candidate uh
it's his first time running for anything
so he's a little green on the trail but
I think his views are really really
solid I think he sees where the future
of the party has to go he's run a good
campaign really good campaign from that
perspective
Blake is surging in Arizona Politico
which had written the the election off
had said that it was uh it was a
Democrat seat has just shifted it back
to a toss-up
Masters has been lagging behind Kelly
for for a while now now a new poll from
Trafalgar and daily wire puts Masters
behind Kelly by one percentage point
very very close race and then you're
getting even better news right now in
the races in Georgia so you've got two
very very important races in Georgia
you've got Herschel Walker versus
Raphael Warnock for the Senate and
theoretically could determine the
balance of the Senate would be very
important for Republican majority and
you've got the governor's race there
because Stacy Abrams has been pretending
to be governor of Georgia ever since she
lost incredible news from Rasmussen
polling
Rasmussen polling which is Republican
leaning but uh still got a good track
record Rasmussen is uh showing Walker Up
by Five Points 48 to 43 percent
Rasmussen shows that uh Brian Kemp has
jumped to a 10-point lead over uh Stacy
Abrams
51-41 so this would be absolutely
humiliating for uh Stacy Abrams because
her whole claim was that in 2018 the
election was rigged it was razor thin
and really it was her race and uh that's
just that claim is just falling apart
right now if she runs again and she
loses by 10 points it's brutal now who
knows what Shenanigans the Democrats are
going to pull they've pulled them before
and they've pulled them in Georgia but
can they pull the kind of shenanigans
that can overcome a 10 point lead I'm
not so sure about that and even Herschel
Walker they threw the kitchen sink at
Herschel Walker in in October they said
he said he's the worst guy in the world
he's committed all these terrible sins
his whole family hates him I mean just
the worst muckety muck dirty filthy kind
of politics and it doesn't seem to have
hurt him very much at all
so what are the Democrats doing about
this the Democrats are looking ahead
and not not only I mean I assume they're
doing their absolute best to salvage
this election but they're looking ahead
they're saying man this is going so
poorly for us that we've already got to
deny the 2024 election
what are you actually suggesting we do
if Trump wins fair and square let's
forget about any like Foul Play or
anything like that if he wins in 2024
what are you going to do are you going
to respect
I mean I don't accept the premise of
your question if he wins in 2024 let's
forget the foul play how can I forget
the foul play window right now if the
Republican wins freely
voting rules right now they are taking
steps to make sure that the 2024
election is not a free and for election
you keep this is concerning pushing that
away
to accept that outcome then that's
concerning I'm not hold on hold on I'm
I'm willing to accept an outcome of a
free and fair election shoddy as of
right now do you believe the 2024
election will be a free and fair
election if black people are denied the
right to vote if there is racist
black people have been the vote has been
taken away from them
this is exaggerating rhetoric
there you have it there you have it
and this shouldn't be surprising to
people who
who understand the leftist point of view
when the left uses the word democracy
they don't really mean democracy
obviously not because they say that
Donald that the people voting for Donald
Trump is a threat to democracy the
people the Italians voting for Georgia
Maloney is a threat to democracy the
hungarians voting for Victor Ruban is a
threat to democracy the people electing
someone
by definition is an expression of
democracy
so obviously democracy doesn't mean what
they seem to think it means for the the
left democracy just means liberalism
and and so
the people have to vote for liberalism
they have to liberalism
necessarily according to the libs has to
Triumph at The Ballot Box in order for
it to be a legitimate election
it's not just that sometimes the
Republicans steal the elections or
sometimes the Democrats daily elections
it's according to the libs
every election that the Democrats win
even if they steal it is legitimate and
every election that the Republicans win
even if it is completely above board you
can't point to a single problem with it
every single election has to be
illegitimate because liberalism and
democracy to them are the exact same
thing
and because the only reason because
liberalism is so manifestly good and
true and in everyone's interests the
only reason that you could not vote for
the liberal is because you were not
permitted to through suppression or you
were misinformed you were deceived it
was a fraud
it's this ignorance it's a false
consciousness you're laying laboring
under but either way it has to be
illegitimate
and it's ironic of course because we've
heard for two years now that the
greatest threat to our democracy is
denying elections they're already
denying the next one of course they will
and what I've been trying to tell people
from the very beginning especially since
we've heard all this hullabaloo BS about
January 6th then the January 6th
committee and the greatest threat to our
country is to deny our sacred democracy
the liberals do not give a damn about
the Democracy they they openly deride
the Democracy when the Democracy elects
people that they don't like stop taking
it seriously stop taking the bait now I
think
uh finally people are getting that
argument because you're seeing that
reflected in the polls the Democrats
went all in it's just amazing they went
all in this year on really two issues
they said the two issues that Americans
care about are
abortion
and January 6th 2021 this this sort of
unruly event at the Capitol that's it
and by the way I care a lot about
abortion I'm very pro-life very very
strongly pro-life
very few people care about abortion on
the pro-life side or the pro-life
approach Choice side when when they're
actually casting their vote it matters
as a top issue to something like 15 of
people
and then on January say no nobody cares
like truly a negative people care cares
about January 6th
so there are they're already trying
to deny it
but of course it is not
illegitimate for the people to reject
liberalism in fact I think the people
should always reject liberalism I think
liberalism is just wrong and bad in all
of its forms it's it should be cast
aside we don't it's not good and people
have good reason to reject the the
liberalism and the terrible liberal
candidates once again even putting aside
that terrible debate performance from
John fetterman against Dr Oz
here again we have a new example of John
fetterman
showing that he is not fit for the U.S
Senate
you know and you know you talk about the
the liver the liberty of statue
um has never had an inscription inside
that said you know send your your tired
100 uh masses and put him on a bus and
turn him into a a cheap political stunt
I I again I don't mean to make fun of uh
fetterman because he has brain damage I
think his wife is obviously a complete
psychopath to put him on the campaign
Trail Democrats obviously very cynical
because his I believe he had his stroke
the day before the primary day right
around the primary so they said well
we're already in it he's going to win
the primary so let's just let's just
weather this thing out and hope that we
can just force him into the Senate and
then he won't do anything in the Senate
we'll we'll do everything for him but
it'll it'll be just fine no big deal
because the the people don't don't
matter here for the for the libs it's
he'll just be one more vote for Joe
Biden one more vote for the liberal
establishment that that's that's fine
and now the people are looking at that
man and they're saying no that's not the
leadership we want so fetterman has a
pretty legit excuse as to why he
is not fair as to why he is giving such
a bad performance on The Campaign Trail
other Democrats don't have that kind of
excuse I think the candidate who's
actually collapsing in real time even
more dramatically than fetterman is
Kathy hokel the governor of New York
Kathy hokel the other day in a debate
with Lee zeldon the Republican who is
beating her right now in the polls
zeldon kept hitting her on crime and
Kathy hokel said
oh lee why is it so important to you to
lock up criminals come on Lee what's a
big deal about this New York voters
looking at her saying lady are you
kidding me crime is spiking everywhere
and yeah I'm with that guy I don't even
know what he believes about anything
else but I'm definitely not with you if
you think crime doesn't matter big big
misstep and then again
just yesterday we see Kathy hokel and
making the closing argument I guess for
her campaign now on the issue of masking
up little toddlers again
so let's talk about exactly what RSV is
these are the symptoms I want parents to
be aware of them I usually fall and
winter it's like a common cold but it
does hit younger children and it's
really frightening it's not new at all
something we've seen before but you know
infants as young as six months old I
have been known to contract this so it's
hard to keep kids safe you know to think
about the fact that a year ago you know
before a year ago a lot of kids were
wearing masks in a daycare center or in
schools and that did give them some
level of protection we're not mandating
this but we're saying parents you know
you got other kids you got kids in
school preschool and you got a baby at
home you really might just want to take
these extra precautions and by now kids
are more socialized to the idea of
wearing a mask it's not as strange to
them it's not as like what is this all
about there's really cute masks out
there I've seen a lot of them so that's
something I'm encouraging all parents to
consider
is this woman trying to lose is she
actually saying what how many days are
we out from the election now
12 or some 11 or 12 days from the
election and she's saying hey parents
I'm not going to mandate it yet but you
should really mask up your two-year-olds
yeah put the masks on two two and a half
years now after more yeah just about two
and a half years after
15 days to slow the spread put put masks
on your two-year-olds vote for us we're
the party of fresh ideas of course not
is they're out of everything
and again I actually see a little bit of
I I think I can see the thought process
here if there was a thought process
which is the Democrats have been dead on
every single campaign issue other than
covid for most of this okay let's double
down covid's very serious because we've
got to go back to code we've got to mask
people up
it's completely it's completely
misreading the moment and misreading the
polls would show that the Democrats are
down even on covid now
they've got nothing left unless they
unless they pull a rabbit out of a hat
to really rig up this election unless
the voting the vote counting takes three
months here they pause it on Election
Day they say oh we got to work something
out don't worry unless that I it just
seems to me that the Democrats are are
like cows on the way to the
slaughterhouse when it comes to these
midterm elections
you know I'm so excited to present to
you a new three-part series from Jordan
Peterson on daily wire plus that is on
marriage I I I'm obviously so grateful
to have a wonderful marriage with sweet
little Elisa with marriage rates at an
all-time low right now in the United
States and a birth rate that is
continuing to fall everyone needs to
watch this series especially young
people the statistics are showing that
younger people are getting married much
later in life and less frequently as
well now I know that our audience here
is not filled with Peter Pan's but just
in case there are a few stragglers there
who are late to the marriage game and or
not you know have not taken holy orders
or says something like that consecrated
singlehood or something consider this a
pleas especially for the boys by the way
consider this a pleasant kick in the
teeth
don't be selfish or as Jordan Peterson
says stop having cocaine fueled binge
parties and make your bed and for those
of you married folks who've let time and
work and outside forces get in the way
Jordan will also show you how to
navigate through those moments and get
back to that romantic fun adventure that
you had at the beginning
daily wire Plus members can watch the
first episode of Jordan Peterson's on
marriage with two more episodes coming
out soon if you're not yet a member go
to dailywire.com Knowles to join today
remember your membership really helps us
prevent the total collapse of society as
we know it
foreign
speaking of kids
Disney
has just fulfilled
one of the the long long-standing dreams
of radical liberals with nothing better
to do than to make up problems Disney
well listen I'll let some random adult
on Twitter
uh explain the significance
this is not a drill all Quote all caps
Disney Plus finally made a short with a
plus size lead
it's called reflect and it's part of the
short circuit short series let's just
say I was sobbing
at first I thought that this was
parody
I don't think it is
I think
what's the story here the story is that
Disney releases short films sometimes
which very few people see
and in this case they made a short film
about a fat girl
and
this does not seem like international
news to me but it was trending on social
media there's been a lot of commentary
about it this is supposed to be very
very significant and apparently it's
very very significant
to this woman not a drill finally
they've finally made a short film about
a fat girl I didn't know this was
something we were all longing for that
anyone really was longing for but it had
finally finally and this one was brought
to
tears over the sobbing
then another adult woman
took to Twitter said
uh 16 year old me needed this Disney
short before I quit ballet because I
didn't want to be the fat girl in class
anymore I'm glad the little ones will
have this 10 out of 10 for reflect it's
so wonderful and so
I look at these two accounts there were
a lot of others these were just the ones
that were lumped in with the trending
the completely viral all over Twitter
adult number one
pronouns in bio
checks out
number two
pronouns in BIO self-identified dog mom
and a teacher so that's good this is who
you want educating your kids right you
always want the pronouns in BIO
educating your kids right no I don't
think so
uh I don't have much of an opinion about
a Disney making a short film about a fat
girl I
okay that's fine I don't watch short
Disney films I don't I don't watch a new
long Disney films I don't
that's okay I
though I I have opinions about a great
many things this is not something that I
have particularly strong feelings about
however
I do have strong feelings
about childless adults
who are completely obsessed with Disney
and more broadly I have strong opinions
about childless adults
who are obsessed with children's things
that's weird you shouldn't do that
I I have friends of mine
who
as adults
childless adults sometimes even just
alone will go to Disney World
or will they just can't wait for the
next children's movie to come out and
they're going to go see the next
children's movie on the the first day of
the movie or they buy toys they buy
children's toys for themselves just to
have the toys and so they get to play
with the toys and that it's it's not
just a few weird people that I'm making
fun of this is a social phenomenon that
seems to be growing in particular among
my generation the Millennials and it's
really weird and it's obviously related
to
the the fact that our generation is not
having children
and they're not getting married and
they're delaying everything and they're
not having as many kids and they're not
having kids at all in many cases
and these are obviously related
because there is there actually is
something natural about wanting to
experience childhood things as an adult
that's called Nostalgia that that's
totally normal
and there's a way to do it the way to do
it is to have kids and then you get to
experience it with your kids you get to
take your kid to the Disney movie and
that's not something that I'm exactly
eager to do but maybe I'll get a kick
out of part of the movie or you know you
buy your kid toys and then you play with
the toys with the kid and that actually
can be kind of fun
that's good that that's that's the right
way to channel your Nostalgia for
childhood and to keep your imagination
alive and all these things the the bad
way is to pretend to be a child a bad
way is to never grow up because when
you're a child You Do child childish
things and when you
the childlike things you know you do the
things that children do
when you grow up you're supposed to when
you become a man you're supposed to put
away the things
of a child
there's actually Kenny Loggins song
about this the Pooh Corner song You Know
help me if you can I've got to get back
you know it's actually a pretty good
song and it's a song he wrote in high
school I've mentioned it once or twice
on the show about how he wandered out
into the Hundred Acre Wood when he's
looking for you know his friends Winnie
the Pooh and everything but he can't
find them he's wandered a little bit too
far today and he can't get back he can't
get back to Childhood because he's
graduating high school now he's becoming
a man and it leaves you with a little
bit of longing but it kind of
some hope for the future and say okay
I'm going to do bigger things now I'm
going to do more adult things now but
and then he when he had children Kenny
Loggins he added a verse to the song he
said I actually did get to go back to
the Hundred Acre Wood because now my
little kid has my little Winnie the
Winnie the Pooh Bear and he's hugging
him and I get to see the world again now
through his eyes wow what a wonderful
thing
but don't for goodness sakes people
don't be overgrown children
whatever who who cares about the fat
girl in the Disney movie or the for
short film or whatever
that doesn't matter
what matters is
you getting really really excited to go
see a kids movie that you shouldn't be
doing that you need if you are getting
really really excited for the kids stuff
you need to grow your interests
and you need to look to hire things
because you're an adult and you got to
act like a man usually I do the Don
Corleone impression when it's some guy
whining about how he can't get a girl or
something like that or he can't but you
it you got to act like a man not just
from the sex perspective but from the
age perspective you gotta act like a man
act like a grown-up what's the matter
with you
speaking of movies
uh there's some advice that's gone viral
on Tick Tock this of course is the
advice that white people
uh who go to see black panther or the
New Black Panther movie on opening
weekend are in fact anti-black
[Music]
this message is to all our would-be
accomplices and white allies this
message is to all the white people who
have BLM in their bio
if you really want to prove to black
people that you love us and you care
about us and you are down for the cause
do not go see that movie opening weekend
you buy your ticket you give it to a
black person or a black family who can't
afford to go and then you go sit at that
theater in front of the doors you make
sure that every black person in that
theater can enjoy that movie in peace
you make sure that you use your body to
block us from anybody who would be
coming in that theater to do us harm
that is your job
you can go see it on another weekend go
see it on the second or third weekend
but the first weekend that's for us to
do anything other than this is
anti-black
so you got to give her credit for a good
grift for a good con it's worked on a
lot of people uh this is what all of the
anti-racism stuff is about it's just a
it's just a power move it's just a con
to say hey give me something hey you
shut up you shut up let me do whatever I
want and that's that's the if you give
me money give me whatever that's all it
is it's a really cynical Shakedown kind
of thing as she is expressing but hey if
the cons working for her I guess uh you
know there's there's some cleverness
involved on this one in particular
though I have to say
fine by me she can have my ticket to the
New Black Panther movie that black
panther was so bad I had to watch it
because daily wire made me because I had
to give a review it was so terrible I
didn't enjoy a single second of it it's
not a good movie and I assume since
sequels are generally not as good as the
first I assume black panther 2 is going
to be even worse so yes
call I am the new ibram Candy
I am basically Robin D'Angelo here you
may lady you may have my ticket to Black
Panther
I don't have a ticket I don't have one
yet but if I find one you can have it
very excited because the best time of
the week is about to start right now
baby our mailbag our mailbag is
sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code Knowles Canada w-les to get 50 off
your first month
all right let's start with the voicemail
bag take it away
hello Michael uh Grant you're an avid
listener from Scotland so I'm hoping to
get married next year in August
um to a wonderful lady who I've known
for about 10 years the interesting thing
is that we're both committed Christians
and we are both urgents we're both 33
years old and we've we've never had sex
we we believe of course
um that sex has been placed within the
bones of marriage by God Society in
general doesn't seem to Value virginity
at all or or saving yourself it's just
seen as a here in the UK it's seen as an
eccentricity
um I've even been
um accused I don't know if that's the
right word it's been suggested that I'm
an insail of course I would argue that
I'm a v sale I'm voluntarily uh celibate
until marriage just wondering if the if
there's the same culture
in the united in the United States as
there is over here I would hope that
public Christianity being somewhat
stronger in the US that there'd be a
more respect for those who wait until
marriage even
um like myself and my fiance people will
wait until they're in their 30s isn't
that a thing would you say thanks
Michael
well uh listen a good on you for for
doing that
um
unfortunately
uh unfortunately in the United States
it's pretty much the same situation the
uh public Christianity has collapsed
broadly the idea of saving you know your
virginity has also basically uh
collapsed and so
um no here in here in the United States
you would be considered eccentric but
it's good sometimes it's very good to be
eccentric and I suspect that we'll serve
you in your marriage so uh stand strong
all right next question
hi Michael my name is Hunter and I'm a
stay-at-home mom to two beautiful little
girls and I have a husband who is the
love of my life and the best man I've
ever known when we met I was all about
the I'm spiritual Christian but not
religious nonsense
that has changed so much over the years
and honestly because of you I'm
seriously considering converting to the
Catholic faith
it is the most important thing to me as
a mother to pass on my faith to my
children
which my husband is totally fine with
my husband however was never raised with
any concept of God regardless of that he
is the most faithful and loving husband
and father I'm wondering what advice you
would give to me to help bring my
husband to God
thank you so much for all you do Michael
oh thanks so much wonderful to hear that
and
you're in a way better position than a
lot of people who write in to the show
and say look I've got a different
religious view from my husband and he's
totally opposed to mine and it's
creating a lot of friction that that's a
tough situation here it seems like your
husband is totally open to it but as you
say he was just not raised without any
freaking proper formation without any
religious formation at all
so I think what you ought to do is a one
you know take your kids to mass and you
know raise them up in the faith as and
you know as you especially as you're
sort of coming into it
and uh
and then I would just tell your husband
look this matters to me
I think it is true I think it is good
and I think it's important
and it's not I think it's very true it's
not just like a kind of take it or leave
a thing I think it's very true I think
it's very good I think it's very
important
and so you're still coming to your
husband and saying look I respect you've
got your own views you're the head of
the household even but this is really
important to me so I would really
it would mean a lot if you would at
least kind of look into it
you know and maybe take it seriously and
maybe I don't know you have him read a
few books on the subject maybe you have
him read the Bible maybe you have him
read
C.S Lewis or GK Chesterton or some more
modern book or some older book or I you
know I don't know you know your husband
better than me or you haven't talked to
a priest or you haven't talked to your
other Catholic friends or who you know
but
introduce him to it it's not his fault
that he doesn't know anything about it
you know and you could play a real role
here in pulling him in and then as my
friend Andrew klavan points out uh if
you play some role in someone converting
then you get an extra toaster in heaven
so that's one I think you're in a good
position and uh I would I would just
nurture that you know that's what
mothers do mothers nurture so you can
you can nurture that keep going
hi Michael so for over a decade now the
left has used institutions with very
large reach such as CNN huffpo and
Kotaku to Target and condemn low profile
individuals for opinions that they view
as racist or sexist and to thus cause
them socioeconomic damage I've noticed
that more recently conservatives have
responded in kind you know examples
include Candace Owens and Libs of tick
tock who are not afraid to call out
individual leftists on Twitter for their
bad behavior and not only do I not
condemn this practice when it comes to
the right I actually applaud it because
first of all we have to fight the left
on their own terms and secondly because
let's face it no one's going to lose
their job because Candace Owens
condemned them my question to you is how
do we determine when to fight the left
on their own Battlefield and when we
have to take a stand for absolute moral
principles even when it will make it
more difficult for us to engage engage
in battle thanks for your moral Clarity
and love the show
thanks very much you you always need to
take a stand for absolute moral
principles
there is never a time when you can get
away from that so and and very often
that's the way that this question is
phrased when do we need to stand up for
our moral principles and when can we get
a little bit looser so we can sling some
mud at the left
that's not that's not the battle that's
not the question
the question is
do we fight tough or do we fight weak
you can fight weak in a very moral way
or I'm sorry you can fight tough in a
very moral way you can fight weak in a
very immoral way you know I mean this
was the absolute lie of of never Trump
and the the kind of squishy types up up
until today is they would say well you
know uh I just want to lose with dignity
there were some there were some people
who had different objections to Trump so
I don't want to paint with too broad a
brush some people who had different
fears and things like that but you know
who I'm talking about I'm talking about
the David French types you know the
David French types who is who
essentially said we need we need to lose
with dignity there's nothing dignified
about that I don't think there's
anything moral about that
so no you could you can own the libs in
a way that is moral where you're
speaking the truth with love for the
good
and you and you can own the libs in a
way that's immoral where you can lie
about people and be you know needlessly
vicious and you know cruel and unjust
and so you could you could obviously do
that too but I think we need to be tough
and moral and I I think that when you're
tough in a moral way you're going to be
much more effective keep going
hey Michael this is Vincent so the
election is pretty uh soon and I'd like
to know if the Republicans win the house
and or Senate what is the number one
priority you think they should focus on
if the Republicans win the house and or
Senate well that's
hmm
depends on if it's just the house or
just the Senate but let's say they win
both what should they do
well
they're going to want to launch all
sorts of Investigations against the left
which they should that should happen but
it shouldn't be the top part of the
agenda
the first thing they have to do is
obstruct so they have to obstruct the
Democrats and Joe Biden's agenda that's
the that's what happens when you've got
divided government you've got the
Democrats have the White House and the
Republicans have the Congress is okay
good first thing stop the bleeding okay
then the Republicans should obstruct
Biden's nominees
in I assume most cases but that that
would be a good start because the
nominees have been absolutely horrific
so you got to stop that
then
really
the only major issue right now where the
Republicans could have real legislative
power before 2024 would be on something
like funding the war in Ukraine which is
really important by the way the war in
Ukraine it well one could see us all go
up and you know smoke in a nuclear war
uh first major war in Europe since World
War II and the threats of nukes have
been lobbed around quite a lot recently
but also it's driving up Energy prices
also threatens to destabilize the entire
world also the energy prices are driving
up inflation so it's having global
effects pretty much everywhere uh what I
I would recommend is that Republicans
use the power of the purse that they
have
and even even the power to declare war
even though I don't think Joe Biden's
gonna ever use that I think he'll just
keep running this proxy war with Russia
without ever actually declaring war
uh
they can use that to force Joe Biden to
negotiate with Russia
and say look
in order to have an effective foreign
policy you need strength and diplomacy
and so forth the Biden Administration
did the worst of all worlds which is
they showed only diplomacy in the
beginning as to the point of inviting
Russia to invade and no strength
whatsoever said we're not going to stop
you from invading and we're also going
to take the sanctions off Nordstrom too
and then once Putin invaded they
completely flipped and now it's all
strength in that they're just funneling
money into Ukraine and fighting a proxy
war and in some cases escalating proxy
worth Russia but no diplomacy whatsoever
so there's no off ramp there's no way to
get out of it I mean you think of the
Cuban Missile Crisis there was the
strength which was the blockade that
Kennedy wouldn't call a blockade around
Cuba but then there was a ton of
diplomacy which is actually what decided
the thing when they took the missiles
out of turkey and when you had constant
contact
between the U.S and Russia to
de-escalate before the war so
Republicans could play an important role
there as well because of the power of
the purse and uh at least in theory the
some some power over the declaration of
war
okay now the old school mailbags hello
Michael
usually arguments against infanticide
are easy to hold ground on
but there's one related point that I'm
unsure of in cases of rape mothers are
morally obligated to give birth to the
child because The Unborn life still has
value does this imply that we are also
morally obligated to donate organs say
kidneys to those who would die without
them since those lives also have value
this line of thinking seems flawed but I
haven't been able to come up with a
simple answer I'm interested in thoughts
both from Catholic perspective and if
applicable how I also might present and
answer an atheist might relate to more
thank you for everything that you do
love the show
sure well my answer I think will satisfy
both of those criteria which is no you
are not morally obligated to donate all
of your organs away to people
even the organs that you don't
necessarily need to function day to day
you know an extra kidney or something
like that and
the reason for this is not the question
hinges not merely on the value of the
other person but it hinges on
the purpose of organs
everything has a purpose an end a t loss
the end of the purpose of the leftist
ears tumbler is to give me delicious
salty life to steers the purpose of the
microphone is to transmit my dulcet
tones into your ears and the purpose of
my kidneys is to filter my blood the
purpose of my lungs is to take in oxygen
and expel carbon dioxide
here is the crucial part the purpose of
a woman's womb is to grow her baby the
purpose of a placenta is to transmit
nutrients between the mother and the the
child and so even from that perspective
a a woman does not have a right to
murder a child in the womb from for all
sorts of reasons
uh but in part because the womb is for
the child and the the mother has an
obligation to love that child and and to
take care of that child that's that's
part of uh purpose and uh so the the
it's it's a purpose of the end of organs
you can see that specifically or just
like the end of all sorts of created
things
um
and more broadly you can see this in the
very purpose of motherhood as motherhood
um but people get very confused about
that because they don't they don't
understand that the physical world could
have
okay you could derive metaphysical
conclusions from the physical world
because we've become very stupid in
modernity and we we just think in this
really shallow materialistic kind of way
which is very incoherent uh but I think
I think that answer would be satisfying
certainly from a Catholic perspective
but also just from the perspective of
the natural law I mean it would be it
was satisfying from the perspective of
philosophy from ancient Greece all the
way up until five minutes ago basically
now we get to
the much more philosophically
satisfying part of the show
and oh I'm sorry physically satisfying
part of the show that is when I kill
Jake crane that's right he lost the
fantasy football game I won it now he
has to eat a poison chip while I watch
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]